okay welcome back everybody I think that
there are three more weeks of class nine
lectures the last week of class there
will be a second midterm I've been told
I can't call it a final it's a midterm
2.0 and it looks like we're actually
gonna finish everything I wanted to tell
you which is kind of amazing so this
week I'm going to tell you about Laplace
transforms which are essentially more
powerful generalization of Fourier
transforms for slightly badly behaved
functions okay
Fourier transforms are a really good
thought experiment and a really good
coordinate system to write functions in
but Laplace transforms are perhaps a bit
more powerful for everyday solving of
equations by hand okay so today I'm
going to tell you what the Laplace
transform is and why we need it and then
in the next two lectures I'm going to
tell you how we use these to solve
ordinary differential equations and
partial differential equations okay and
how many of you have seen Laplace
transforms before okay how many of you
have seen them used to solve Odie's like
the harmonic oscillator okay what about
in control systems maybe a little bit
okay so this is going to be a review for
maybe about a third to a half of you but
that's okay we're gonna go a little bit
more in depth and we're gonna make
connections to the Fourier transform and
also make connections between Oh des and
P DS so I apologize if things kind of
jump back and forth a little bit this
entire week is going to be Laplace
transforms we will do a little bit in
MATLAB kind of how MATLAB deals with
Laplace transforms and then in the last
two weeks we're gonna get back to data
and numerix things like that okay any
questions at all about anything right
now questions about the organization
what we're learning why we're learning
at big-picture
anything I have it I think this is a
short lecture
okay maybe I'll just jump in so the
Fourier transform allowed us to
generalize Fourier series to what types
of functions also Fourier series were
defined for periodic functions and we
allow these to generalize to non
periodic functions over the entire real
axis from minus infinity to infinity
okay so the Fourier transform hey let's
try one more time
alright so the Fourier transform is
defined on the entire real axis from
minus infinity to infinity let's say
from X in minus infinity to infinity and
it's also defined for well-behaved
functions and what do I mean by a
well-behaved function in this context
so it actually doesn't have to be
continuous my function can be
discontinuous and I can still do the
Fourier transform like I can do the
square wave it's not perfect but in the
limit then my Fourier transform is fine
what other types of functions are are
well they have one of the other
properties of F that make it so I can do
a Fourier transform so it doesn't have
to be smooth doesn't have to be
continuous but it has to be it can only
have countably many discontinuities
meaning it can only have like I should
be able to count the number of
discontinuities they should be ordered
in some way what is the kind of main
property of the Fourier transform
function f not periodic doesn't have to
be periodic it has to taper off to 0 at
an infinity right it has to be a bounded
l1 function meaning it doesn't blow up
as X goes to infinity so the magnitude
so my function f of X has to go to 0 as
the magnitude of X goes to infinity so
this is bounded asymptotically actually
more than bounded it converges to 0 so
bounded asymptotically to 0 and that
just is a way of saying that our
function tapers off to 0 as X goes to
plus or minus infinity but lots of
functions that we're interested in don't
do this like what are some example
functions that we see all the time that
don't have this property sign sorry
ramp function or a Heaviside function so
the Heaviside is a good one so it's not
heavy like this is a heavy rock it's
heavy side like the person who invented
it was named heavyset it's a very
convenient name because his function
looks like a heavy side function
starting at zero so zero everywhere so
if I wanted to write this formally I
would say at each of X equals zero for X
less than 0 1 for X greater than zero
and I don't really care what happens
exactly at x equals zero so I'm not
going to include it so this is a
function that we use all the time in
control theory and I'll show you what
why this is useful later a ramp function
would also be an example what are some
other functions that are not bounded and
not well behaved maybe even blow-up
Exponential's are good cosine sines
Exponential's heavy sides ramps all
kinds of functions polynomials x squared
right X cubed x to the fourth these are
all functions we want to be able to work
with Fourier transforms can't handle
them ok so I'm in a bad situation here
so what is what's a possible solution
what if I want a Fourier transform these
functions but they're gonna blow up they
blow up as X goes to plus and minus
infinity what's the possible way I can
fix this
I could take derivatives but oftentimes
if my function blows up then the
derivatives also blocked so
Exponential's will blow up this
Heaviside derivative will be pretty well
behaved except it'll have a delta
function at zero I can Fourier transform
a delta function no problem what are
some other ideas what could I do to
these functions to make them better
behaved so I can take the Fourier
transform what's the fundamental problem
we're having they're not converging
they're not going to zero how do I make
a function go to zero and plus a minus
sorry well I don't want to divide one by
FX because then it might blow up at the
origin or might blow up somewhere else
that's kind of a dangerous way to try to
make this converge yeah so maybe I'll
multiply it by a really really strongly
decaying function kind of regularizes
down to zero so the solution that's
exactly right so the solution would be
to multiply our badly behaved function
let's call this I'm gonna switch to time
in Fourier domain I usually have
functions of X in the plas time and I
usually think of them as functions of
time for reasons you'll see very very
shortly so I take my badly behaved
function of time and multiply by strong
strongly damped or strongly decaying
function
and that strongly decaying function is
going to look like e to the minus gamma
T so I have some new function big f of T
equals e to the minus gamma T times my
original badly behaved function f of T
and I'm gonna choose this gamma large
enough that this is forced to decay for
time going to positive infinity okay and
then I'm gonna Fourier transform big F
so I want to be doing this Fourier
transform I still think that Fourier
transforms are going to be a useful
concept but I can't do Fourier
transforms on my badly behaved function
so I multiply them by R really largely
damped exponential and then I can
Fourier transform this okay so and what
we're going to do is we're only going to
consider positive time so T greater than
zero
there's a couple of reasons for this the
first reason is if my badly behaved
function is badly behaved in both
negative and positive infinity then
there's no function I can't multiply it
by this function and make it decay on
either side okay so if I want to
multiply this by a simple exponential
decay function then this is only going
to decay for time going to positive
infinity if I wanted to multiply this by
a function that would decay in negative
and positive infinity what would I do
I've multiplied by a Gaussian right I'd
multiply it by each of the minus gamma T
squared a Gaussian that'd be fine and
you could very well define a two-sided
regularizing a something like a Laplace
transform but for plus and minus
infinity you could totally do that I'm
sure this has a name I don't know what
it's called but there's a lot of these
named transforms but I'm switching to
variable time because we usually care
about what's happening after now I don't
care about what happened in the past I
start now and I care about things
converging to positive infinity so we
can do this trick of multiplying by a
decaying function and we're only going
to consider positive times so
Laplace transforms we usually think of
as referring to time they could refer to
to space and we'll do that later okay so
our function f of T is really equal to
zero for time less than zero and it's
equal to this thing each of the minus
gamma T F of T for T greater than zero
okay and there's a couple of assumptions
we're making so we assumed and these are
pretty reasonable assumptions that I
think you'll agree so we assume that our
function f of T is always bounded by
some constant e to the Alpha T for some
K and some alpha alpha can be positive
it could be a thousand or a million it
could be a hugely fastly growing
exponential but we're assuming that F is
bounded by some you know some
exponential which most functions we care
about are try to think of a really nasty
function that's not bounded by an
exponential we don't have a lot of them
in our arsenal most functions we care
about are at least bounded by an
exponential okay
so we assume that f our function is
badly behaved but it's not arbitrarily
badly behaved it at least is bounded by
some exponential growth and we choose
gamma to be larger than alpha so we
choose our decay so basically we choose
our damping gamma is larger than the
growth alpha okay so this is just a kind
of mathematically precise way of
guaranteeing that this function f of T
is going to converge like I want it to
meaning that I can do the Fourier
transform let's make sense okay we want
to be able to generalize Fourier
transforms to badly behaved functions we
do it this way lots of other ways you
could do it but this is particularly
nice because doing integrals with
Exponential's is particularly
really easy I don't want to do gaussians
because their pain I don't want to do
some other function because they're also
paying this is the easiest function I
can multiply by and make this
well-behaved okay if there's any
questions please interrupt at any time
okay so the next part is simple we're
going to Fourier transform this new
function big f of T and we're going to
see how that relates to our little
function little F of T so I'm saying
that this is generally true for
functions of time T greater than zero
but you could also imagine that I could
have this infinitely long thin piece of
metal this rod except it's only half of
infinity it starts at x equals zero and
it goes to that direction to positive
infinity but it doesn't go in that
direction to positive infinity so I can
also think of Laplace transforms over
some finite region some some infinite
but half infinite region of space and
we'll do that later on Friday doesn't
matter what the variable is it's just
time makes a lot of sense okay so now
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
Fourier transform this big function f
and we're gonna see we're going to
essentially derive the Laplace transform
from the Fourier transform of this big
function f okay so Fourier transform of
f of T equals e to the minus gamma t F
little F of T okay so what's my Fourier
transform big f hat of Omega equals you
guys should know this by heart now this
should be something if you wake up in
the middle of the night you should be
able to recite this when you're groggy
come on
yeah there's an integral K goes from
negative infinity to infinity of e to
the minus I Omega T times this whole
thing e to the minus gamma T F of T DT I
mess that up or is that right
seems right okay good and because this
function f is only defined on positive T
everything you know minus infinity to
zero is equal to zero okay so I'm just
going to say that this is equal to the
integral 0 to infinity of I'm gonna use
shorthand here this is really F of T e
to the I Omega T DT and what about the
inverse Fourier transform F of T equals
1 over 2 pi integral now this really is
an integral from minus infinity to
infinity because my frequency Omega can
still be defined on all positive and
negative frequencies of F hat Omega each
of the positive I Omega T D Omega and
the last thing I'm just writing down the
Fourier transform in terms of F this is
something this is totally review we know
what this is but now I'm going to take
this F hat and I'm going to replace it
by this expression here so I'm going to
get 1 over 2 pi times the integral minus
infinity to infinity of e to the I Omega
T integral 0 to infinity of f of tau e
to the minus I Omega tau D tau on this
integral D Omega on this integral
yes okay good okay so what I really want
to do is I want to find a transform in
terms of my original function little F
so everywhere I see a big F I'm going to
replace it with E to the minus gamma T
little F of T ok and what I'm
essentially going to do is I'm going to
try to find something like so notice
that f of T equals some nasty double
transform of F of T this is basically
saying that if I Fourier transform F and
then I inverse Fourier transform F I get
back F and I want to find a similar pair
a similar Fourier inverse Fourier
transform pair for a little F so that's
that's where we're going this is a
little bit long-winded but I want to
tell you where we're going okay so I
noticed that this is e to the minus
gamma T little F of T and that equals 1
over 2 pi integral minus infinity to
infinity of this thing e to the I Omega
T integral 0 to infinity of F of T times
e to the minus gamma T times e to the
minus I Omega T is e to the minus gamma
plus I Omega this should be Taos
D tau D Omega
okay we're almost there super close so
the last thing we want to do now now we
have some you know f of t equals some
transform of a transform of F this is
getting very close to what we want
except we need to get rid of this
exponential on both sides so I'm going
to multiply both sides by e to the
positive gamma T times e to the positive
gamma T so I'm going to get my function
of time is equal to 1 over 2 pi integral
minus infinity to infinity each of the
gamma plus I Omega T because I
multiplied both sides by e to the gamma
t times the integral 0 to infinity f of
tau e to the minus gamma plus I Omega
tau D tau D Omega ok good so this is
looking strikingly like a Fourier
transform pair except instead of e to
the I Omega T I have e to the gamma plus
I Omega T ok so I Omega has been
replaced by gamma plus I Omega should I
put this down ok the last step is
actually kind of breaking this up into
two transforms a forward Laplace
transform and an inverse Laplace
transform ok so what we're going to do
is we're essentially going to give this
gamma plus I Omega a dummy variable
we're gonna say let s equal gamma plus I
Omega be our Laplace variable and
essentially this is a generalized
frequency
and we'll talk about what that means to
me a generalized frequency of just a
minute it's pretty pretty simple so what
is des if I took at the differential DSO
would es equal D gamma plus idea Meghan
but gamma is a constant D game is zero
so this is just AI D Omega which means
that D Omega and my differential in
omega is equal to D s over I so
everywhere in that integral where I see
a D Omega I'm gonna just swap it out
with a d s divided by I so the last
thing we have is f of time equals 1 over
2 pi and I'm gonna pop this I'm going to
convert this to D s over I and I'm going
to take the I out so this is one of our
2 pi integral now instead of D Omega I'm
integrating with respect to D s so if I
was if I was integrating from Omega
equals minus infinity to infinity then s
is going from gamma minus I in Finity to
gamma plus I infinity my S variable is
gamma plus I Omega gamma plus I Omega
and Omega was going from minus infinity
to plus infinity so this is an integral
from gamma minus i infinity to gamma
plus i infinity of each of the st
remember that's gamma plus I Omega is
just s times the integral from 0 to
infinity of f of tau e to the minus s
tau D tau D s
okay we're super super super close now
this is almost exactly like the Fourier
transform pair and now I can actually
split this up I can say okay my my
Laplace transform variable I'm gonna
call it instead of a hat for Fourier I'm
giving it a flat bar hat and instead of
being a function of Omega it's a
function of s which is gamma plus I
Omega so this Laplace transform this is
the Laplace transform of my function of
T and it's just equal to this integral
here so integral 0 to infinity of f of t
e to the minus s T DT good and my
inverse Laplace transform so if I want
to get my function of time back I take
the inverse Laplace transform of f bar
and that equals 1 over 2 pi integral
from gamma minus I infinity to gamma
plus I infinity of f bar of s e to the
positive st d s that's a shame that i
don't have a red pen because this would
have big red stars because this is
extremely important ok so the Laplace
transform is just a Fourier transform of
my function times an exponential decay
that's all it is and if I go through
those steps on the left reconfiguring
this thing I can find these new
functions this simplification this is
like just simplifying my expression I
get this new expression f bar of a new
frequency variable s is equal to this
function and this is its inverse Laplace
transform
okay this is a good place to stop and
wait for questions yeah good okay we
want to Fourier transform function app
but it's badly behaved so first we
multiply it by an exponential decay and
then we Fourier transform it and in the
process of Fourier transforming our
decayed kind of nice function big f I
essentially try to write it I try to
write big f equals inverse Fourier
transform of Fourier transform of F so
that's I want a pair of Fourier
transform and inverse Fourier transform
and then I plug in my exponential decay
everywhere I see my F and I simplify
simplify simplify until I get something
that's like my original function times
some inverse transform times some
transform of F and this transform looks
remarkably like the Fourier transform
but it's a little different instead of
integrating from i minus i infinity to i
infinity i'm integrating from gamma plus
i minus i infinity to gamma plus i
affinity so it's basically a fourier
transform except i'm integrating on a
different contour and I should draw that
picture
okay so originally
so for my inverse Fourier transform this
is in the complex plane I have minus i
infinity and I infinity up here so
normally what I do for the Fourier
transform is I'd have something like 1
over 2 pi integral minus infinity to
infinity e to the I Omega T F of T so I
would integrate from here all the way up
here and that's how I would get my my
inverse Fourier transform but now
because my function f might be unstable
I have to multiply it by some e to the
minus gamma T and so my inverse Laplace
transform contour integral is along this
curve from gamma minus i infinity up to
gamma plus i infinity where gamma is
larger than the largest growth of f so i
have to do this integral here and
remember when we did complex analysis we
actually know how to compute this
integral because maybe our function may
be this function here has some poles
some you know divided by s minus a is
maybe it has some poles maybe it's even
unstable but i can still take this
contour integral and essentially compute
this large closed integral I can use the
Koshi integral formula and the ML bound
to prove that this part has to be 0 and
I can get an expression for what this
integral equals in terms of the sum of
all the Cauchy integral formula terms
would it help if I wrote down what the
Fourier transform pair was yes I think
so ok
because I really want to convince you
that this Laplace transform is it really
is the Fourier transform on my function
if I multiply it by e to the minus gamma
T that's exactly what I did I Fourier
transformed my function times e to the
minus gamma T so let's say and I and
what I want to get at is if my function
is well-behaved then this actually turns
exactly back into the Fourier transform
or almost exactly from except it's on 0
to infinity instead of minus infinity to
infinity so what will my normal Fourier
transform look like so that would be f
hat of Omega equals integral from minus
infinity to infinity of F of T e to the
minus I Omega T DT and the inverse
Fourier transform F of T if I want to
get that back it's 1 over 2 pi integral
minus infinity to infinity of my Fourier
transform F hat times e to the plus I
Omega T D Omega so let's say that my
function f down here is actually
well-behaved it is bounded at plus and
minus infinity and I don't have to
multiply it by any decay so gamma is 0 I
just multiplied by 1 e to the 0 of T ok
so let's say that now we have s equals
gamma plus I Omega but gamma is 0 so
it's just equals I Omega so here I'm
integrating you know anytime you see an
S plug in an I Omega right so this is e
to the minus I Omega T and I'm
integrating from 0 to infinity because F
is equal to 0 for negative x so this is
still this is actually equal to minus
infinity to infinity of f of t e to the
minus s T DT if f of T is equal to 0 for
negative time right if this function is
0
for negative time then I can make this a
negative infinity to infinity and this
looks exactly like the Fourier transform
if my function was already well behaved
now how about the inverse Fourier
transform part ok so remember our D s
equals 1 over I D Omega now that's not
right D s equals I D Omega so my eyes
cancel and if my function was well
behaved in gamma is 0 and so this is
just the integral for minus I infinity
to I infinity so minus infinity to
infinity and instead of an S here I
would have an I Omega and here I have an
I Omega these are identical transforms
if my function f is well behaved and is
equal to 0 for negative time identical
so the Laplace transform is purely a
generalization of the Fourier transform
for functions that are not well behaved
where I do have to multiply by a real
damping and where my function is
definitely only defined for positive
time and you can think of it basically
like doing the Fourier transform of that
new function that that has been made to
decay ok other questions about this
yeah it can't transform things that grow
faster than exponential any examples
anyone can give me a things that grow
faster than Exponential's excellent XS
enlarged power is actually smaller than
exponential growth if you took the log
of it it would be
it basically is exponential growth but
in a different base I think the vertical
asymptote sorry anything with the
vertical asymptote anything with a
vertical asymptote so if I had like Y
dot equals minus y squared this will
blow up to infinity in finite time I
think not this this is a bad one
there are OD E's that whose solutions
blow up to infinity and finite time and
the solutions would definitely not work
another example is the factorial
function okay so if I have like maybe
like f of T equals T factorial so this
is only defined on integers right but if
I had zipper under the factorial
function like 5 factorial is 5 times 4
times 3 times 2 times 1 so it's huge 10
factorial is way bigger a million
factorial is astronomically large
factorial grows faster than almost
anything else and there's a
generalization of factorial called the
gamma function so it extends factorial
to real-valued numbers so you can have
but basically gamma is way way WAY worse
than exponential it's like a factorial
and so so the Laplace transform doesn't
work for everything but it works for
most things that were comfortable with
power functions exponential functions
even really really nasty exponential
functions are fine
I think if I had eetu the t-squared
would that work
I don't think so but I don't know for
sure I don't think it would work but you
could make another generalize Laplace
transform where instead of multiplying
it by e to the minus gamma T you
multiplied it by that Gaussian we talked
about you could do it even more
generalized transform that would be
totally fine yeah so this has very nice
properties it has nice properties when I
want to Laplace transform the derivative
of a function and if I want to multiply
wanted to Laplace transform the
convolution of two functions so for a
number of reasons we want to do this
it's much easier to compute it works for
almost all functions we would ever care
about for real systems and dynamics and
differential equations for control
systems it has very nice properties with
derivatives and convolution that are
inherited from the Fourier transform and
it's not clear that those would all be
true if I used a different kernel if I
use a different eetu the gamma t because
a lot of what we're going to show for
because if I use each of the when I say
F of T equals e to the minus gamma T
times little F of T this e to the minus
gamma T fits in really nicely to my
Fourier transform and I still get an
exponential of my Laplace variable times
time and if I had this be some Gaussian
then it wouldn't be that simple and
everything would probably break and I
probably wouldn't have any of my nice
properties and this wouldn't work very
well for solving differential equations
but you can try it I've never tried it I
think would be interesting might be the
kind of thing I would put on an exam at
some point in time okay
I'm gonna erase this any other questions
about the Laplace transform I think we
should do some examples basically the
Laplace transform acts almost
identically to a Fourier transform
except we can deal with a larger class
of problems now and so we can also deal
with more OD ease and more PD ease the
we could with the Fourier transform and
we're gonna see that this is really a
very very powerful way of solving
differential equations is to take my
equations Laplace transform them solve
it in the Laplace domain and an inverse
Laplace transform just like we did with
Fourier transforms but now we can deal
with more functions that are like we can
deal with sines and cosines and
Exponential's and all the things we
think we're going to be using okay these
are not my notes okay so let's do a
couple of examples and then I'll give
you a couple of properties and then
we'll end ok so examples so let's say
that I have my function f of T and I
love plus transform F and I get F hat of
s s bar or f bar of s so I'm just going
to do some examples we're going to go
down and see what some of these examples
are so what if my function f of T equals
1 how do I Laplace transform this
the Laplace transform is super super
simple like it's easy to compute the
Laplace transform it's the integral zero
to infinity
each of the minus ste times my function
which is one DT so what's the integral
of this exponential with respect to time
minus one over s e to the minus s T and
I'm evaluating it at zero I should just
do this so this is equal to minus 1 over
s e to the minus s T evaluated from zero
to infinity so each of the minus
infinity zero right so this equals zero
minus minus so minus minus is plus 1
over s e to the 0 and e to the 0 is 1 so
this is 1 over s just positive 1 over s
everyone follow that I integrated this
but it since it's a definite integral I
actually have to plug in my values and
so that's where the minus minus becomes
a plus ok good what about another
example what about f of T equals e to
the a T integral 0 to infinity each of
the a minus s T DT that's the same as F
of T times e to the minus s T again if I
integrate this with respect to time I
get minus 1 over a minus s but then I
get a minus minus and everything works
out again and this ends up being 1 over
s minus a
these should look really familiar to a
lot of you and also remember we learned
how to inverse Laplace form Laplace form
inverse Laplace transform this function
in the complex analysis part we did that
horrible nasty Bromwich integral over
there to compute the inverse Fourier
Laplace transform of this and we ended
up getting this function inverse Laplace
transforms are generally super nasty and
we're not going to do much of that okay
but you know how in principle ok other
ones that are important so f of T equals
sine of some frequency times time or
equals cosine of some frequency times
time then s hat would equal either a
over s squared plus a squared or it
would be s over s squared plus a squared
so Laplace transform of cosine is s over
s squared plus a squared what about if
my function was a polynomial t to the
power n I can Laplace transform this no
problem to Laplace transform this I
assumed you would just use the
convolution property and which I haven't
told you yet but I will seem so f bar of
s equals n factorial divided by s to the
power n plus 1 so it's kind of like
integrating a bunch it's kind of like
this 1 over s a bunch of times you can
also do this for Heaviside functions and
for any other functions you can find
them in the notes just Google Laplace
transform table and you'll see you know
like a hundred of these and you should
you should look at them and just make
sure that you're familiar with a few of
the most important ones ok good easy to
compute the Laplace transform fairly
difficult to compute the inverse Laplace
transform but we have tricks and we only
have to do the hard step once and we
have lookup tables ok so I wanted you to
know how you would do it if you ever
needed to
but in principle we're just going to use
lookup
for inverse Laplace transforms or MATLAB
or Mathematica or whatever okay the last
thing that actually makes this useful is
the fact that just like in the Fourier
transform if I took the Fourier
transform of the derivative of my
function I ended up getting something
much simpler in the frequency domain and
that's also true of the Laplace
transform because it's basically a
generalized Fourier transform so I think
that the reason this is called the
Laplace transform I don't actually think
Laplace invented the Laplace transform
but Laplace was the first person to
actually use the Laplace transform to
solve OD es and PD es and he was really
thinking in the frequency domain where
you can do all of your math much more
easily yeah he had that insight that you
should be doing your math in the Laplace
transform domain so that's really why
it's called Laplace transform
okay so important properties and I'll
probably just have time to write down
one or two of these so the derivative
property is by far the most important
the derivative and the convolution just
like in Fourier transforms so if f bar
of s equals my Laplace transform of F of
T then I want to know what is the
Laplace transform of DF DT of F dot
what's the Laplace transform of f dot
okay so let's actually plug this in
what's the Laplace transform formula
zero to infinity df/dt
a function e to the minus st and we're
integrating with respect to time to get
rid of time to go to the frequency
domain okay just like in the Fourier
transform how do I solve this
integration by parts so I say this one
is d u u DV sorry DV and this one is U
and so if I want to integrate this by
parts I say well that's equal to u DV
sorry u v which is just F of T e to the
minus s T so u V evaluated at zero to
infinity minus the integral of VDU which
is f of T V and then D this with respect
to time is just minus s e to the minus s
T and I'm going to pop my minus s out
front because I'm integrating with
respect to time okay so this right-hand
part is actually really simple now it's
just s times the Laplace transform of F
before when we did Fourier transforms
this term went to zero does anyone
remember why because it was from minus
infinity to infinity and my function f
was guaranteed to be zero but that's not
true here this is a little bit
interesting so it is true in plus
infinity e to the minus s T is going to
be 0 and so this whole thing is 0 for
plus infinity but for 0 I get minus my
function evaluated at time 0 times e to
the 0 s which is 1 so I get this extra
term that comes out I have a constant in
addition plus s times the Laplace
transform of my original function so
it's very very very similar to doing the
for
transform of a derivative except it's a
little different everything's a little
different in a frequency domain I have a
constant term that I pick up my function
evaluated at time zero and but this term
looks basically the same remember s if I
plugged in I Omega this would be the
Fourier transform of the derivative
all right Fourier transform of the
derivative is I Omega Fourier f hat yeah
great question
yeah I think you would say that this is
zero plus let's talk a little bit more
about that later it's a little that's it
that's a really good question okay this
is a derivative makes sense we derived
it it's like integration by parts pretty
simple and it's very very similar to the
Fourier transform right this term is
identical to the Fourier transform if my
function f was well behaved and s equals
I Omega okay you can also do this for
higher derivatives and you just get more
and more terms you can check it out in
the notes just please look at it in the
notes you can do this for higher
derivatives and it's just integration by
parts again and again and again and it's
easy but it's also kind of horrible you
can do this for convolution so if F bar
equals the Laplace transform of F of T
and G bar equals the Laplace transform
of G of T then the Laplace transform of
F convolution with G is equal to the
Laplace transform of F times the Laplace
transform of G so this is I can't
overstate this in the frequency domain
if I multiply two functions that's like
taking the convolution of those two
functions in the time domain very very
important multiplication is a lot easier
than doing a convolution integral right
point wise multiplication for every
frequency s much easier than doing this
nasty convolution integral so this is a
better representation for a lot of
systems if I have a convolution I might
want to Laplace transform it and things
become a lot simpler so we're gonna see
why this is useful and why this is why
these two properties are useful we're
gonna start solving ode ease and control
systems on Wednesday and then on Friday
and Monday we're going to get into P DS
okay so think about this think about how
this is the same as Fourier transform
this is not a huge stretch it's just a
generalized Fourier transform and on
Wednesday we're really going to see how
much simpler problems are when we
Laplace transform first okay thank you
you